[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm a researcher from the
squid research lab i've been
meticulously studying the mysterious
squids that can transform into humanoid
form
what you just saw was the latest
research footage from splatoon 3.
allow me to share a bit of what we know
so far
splatoon 3 takes place in splatsville
it's known as the city of chaos
centered around splattsville are the
splatlands a place long inhabited by
advanced sea creatures such as squids
and octopuses
buildings spanning several generations
are crammed into the city creating its
distinctive culture
in the splatlands turf war appears to be
a popular activity
its basic rules are unchanged two four
player teams compete against each other
to ink the most area
however
the trend seems to have undergone a
major shift with the existence of new
main and special weapons confirmed in
the footage
in the latter portion of the footage we
were able to observe activities from
story mode the single player campaign
return of the mammalians
meaning the reappearance of mammals
appears to be the theme of story mode
this time around
what could this possibly mean in a world
where all mammals except for two cats
have vanished
[Music]
it appears that there's still a lot to
uncover
but we'll continue with our research and
keep you updated once more results
become available
please look forward to more
splatoon 3.
[Music]
updates to come
see you next time